a Red Room is a room where you can live
stream the murderer torture of a
individual I've bet someone to go find
one and show it to me I'm sure someone
has done it
hi I'm Pizza bagel I'm going by
confidentiality in my own safety I was
the executive business director of
extremely large illegal enterprise I
made well over eight digits on the dark
web I'm here today with BuzzFeed to help
smell some myths about the dark web what
are the difference between the clear net
the dark net and the deep web if you
want to think about it like an iceberg
you have what's showing above the
waterline right so you have just a
little bit of the iceberg you have the
waterline and that water line is where
stuff starts you get murky then you're
getting into the deep web and if you
don't know icebergs are significantly
larger under it's just the tip of a
mountain versus the whole Mountain
anything that's not indexed by storage
engine as in anything that you can't
pull up on Google so it's not ending in
a normal domain calm cold it is part of
the Deep Web if something is on the Deep
Web in this parts of the Deep Web that
starts into criminal activity that is
the dark web both are legal to access is
it illegal to go on the dark web that is
a very common myth it is not illegal to
go on both the dark all the Deep Web you
can sign up and you can freely browse
any large dark net marketplace
researchers law enforcement and normal
citizens do it all the time without any
legal repercussions where the legal
trouble starts is when you start buying
things shipping things in distributing
content that is where you get into
trouble is the dark web bigger than the
clear net yes the dark web is
significantly larger than the clear net
on average about four to five hundred
times larger than the clear net our red
room is real red room is a room commonly
painted red where you can live stream
the murder or torture of a individual
while you can't say nothing exists right
I'm sure someone has done it I have
never heard of it never seen it never
heard of it talked about and I've even
been in bets but they don't exist I've
bet someone to go find one and show it
to me and they couldn't maybe they do
exist and when you do hear about them
they are often private it's not a public
done thing and you hire a hitman on the
dark one well the one or two might exist
and with him and in his law so hitmen
are real thing from history and still in
reality but they are not remotely common
I've never heard of someone getting a
hit placed on them I've never
heard of someone who is taking money to
go do it the hitman that you hear about
more or would be internal people so it
would be when you had organized crime
with large gangs it would be gang
sending one of their members to go do it
but these freelance guys who are taking
large sums of cash to go do it never
seen or heard of that in practice those
transactions are often not from the dark
web or from the internet more than in
person connection true or false the dark
web is evil I would have to mostly
disagree with that the Deep Web helps to
support journalists and people and
censor prone countries lair can help to
get information out and help you get
information in like movies and spread
awareness especially Western culture so
I would say I do not believe this evil
because it does mostly have positive
intentions are there secret lairs to the
dark web so the dark web is accessed
through a browser called tol and it's
called be Onion Router similar to an
onion there are layers Wow there are
different parts and they do tend to
clump together I would not say it is
like layer to layer a lot of stuff just
links to other stuff can you buy
passwords and credit card information on
the dark web yes you can buy passwords
credit card information zoo security
numbers and a lot of stuff they tend to
be randomly selected you're not going to
go chase out or someone and if you are
afraid of that I would heavily recommend
using a password Locker application they
are there to help protect you the people
mostly affected by these security
breaches are people who don't take their
security seriously
are there certain sectors to the deeper
dark web that are isolated from the rest
of the web yes and no there are
communities they're not large they tend
to this to be internet forums to where
people can basically build off each
other they are usually dedicated to
something certain so you have hackers
you have people who want to go find
Atlantis you have people who operate on
the dark and about how the moon landing
was faked they don't want NASA to come
assassinate them you do get these hidden
sectors but they're not as hidden as
much as they are just isolated due to
the outlandish nests of the subject the
dark web is something that has a lot of
rumors about it and it's seen in a very
negative light and I think that we need
to overcome it the dark web started and
still largely operates as a safe space
for people to convey ideas messages
without fear of repercussions in the
one big thing that I want to hit home
and I hope everyone can take home from
watching this video is the darknet does
not look like it has dark mode enabled
it is not a scary black background with
lines of code going on it is a very nice
and clean user interface so the deeper
dark web hosts use a safe space and I
think that we need to reduce the stigma
behind it
[Music]
[Applause]